- Welcome back, everybody.
My next guest is a
four-time Grammy-winning
recording artist, that's
four, okay, who encouraged
all the independent women out
there to put their hands up.
Now she's a mom, has new
music and she's on a mission
to raise awareness about how hard
the African-American community
has been hit by COVID-19.
Let's say hi to Kelly Rowland
What's up, Kelly?
- Hello, Kelly.
I love that--
- I love you, first of all,
I love your song "Kelly".
I jam to it all the time.
- Thank you
- I mean, obviously, I love
your song, "Kelly", obviously,
but I'm just it's I love that song.
I'm trying to figure out a
way to cover it on my show
without looking stupid but I
love, I just love that song,
It's so great but I do want to get to why
you wanna talk here today.
It's important to me as well.
Actually my house manager,
one of my really good friends,
Ava, we've been talking about
this because she's in LA
holding our house down for
us and I'm like don't go out
because it's worse for African-Americans
and where are you right
now and how is quarantine
going for you though?
- The quarantine is going
good and you're actually
absolutely spot on right, Kelly.
It's funny when you start
to think about the ratio
and population of black
people, we only make up 13%,
which, of course, makes us minority
but it's 33% of COVID
patients are African-American,
and some of them were African-American,
because of course, you
know, the virus comes
and it's so many different
types, and I don't,
it's just so mind-blowing,
but 30 that's a big number
33% of patients are African-American,
and we have to get that
number down and I don't know
what's making people feel
like either it can't happen
to them whether they're in
African-American community
or not, but you have
to take this seriously
because one thing happens
like right after another,
which is oh, you go
out, your friend has it,
your friend gives it to
you, you give it to grandma,
then auntie, then this person,
then those people give it
to someone else.
That's how it spreads so
fast and we just have to take
this way more serious
and you gotta think about
also the the illnesses
from high blood pressure,
high cholesterol, hypertension, asthma,
so many different illnesses that have been
really generational, illnesses in
the African-American community.
- And if you have those, getting
COVID makes it worse, yeah.
- Yeah, we just wanna
be smart about all this
and I just really wanna encourage
everyone to stay inside.
We're not quite done
with this but we can be
if we really practice our
social distancing and have,
I like to say kindness, because
when you actually approach
this with kindness, then you'll
think about the fact that
I don't want this to happen
to me and let me just be kind,
stay in my home and be
smart about all of this.
- And be kind to others, be
respectful because maybe you
have an okay immune system
and maybe you might be fine.
First of all, I do love
a level of invincibility.
People think they're
invincible like, they watch
and they're like oh that
happens to someone else
I'm like, you could be that
someone else really quick.
It's a crazy time right now but,
in quarantine for me coming
back to your question
has been nuts because you
know we have three kids
with us right now, our
18-year-old's in Florida
but we have a lot of
kids, a lot of homework,
a lot of cooking, a lot of still working.
Its been a really hard
go, I'm not gonna lie
there's not a self help book
in the world that could help
my psyche last week. (laughs)
- No, not at all.
- How is yours going, is yours nuts?
- It's going good like literally
you could probably hear
Titan in the back on the Zoom
call with this classroom.
- My little Remi is right in
there watching Mickey Mouse so.
- It's real so between that
and he's the only child
I do wanna have another one so bad
but he's by himself so
he expects my attention
at home all the time,
which is sometimes overwhelming
and I still have work to do
and putting out music and finishing up
literally finishing up an
album which I'm very excited.
I cannot wait to get out of quarantine.
I'd love to play you some
records but it's just really
I feel bad for him because
I also had to think about
the fact that the same way
I'm trying to think about
all this and like, flushed
all of these thoughts out,
so is he.
So at like the most
random times of the day,
he'll just act out and then
I'll hone in on him and like,
look at him and then I know
like play therapy works
with him so we'll start playing with cars.
And after a while, I'm
like, do you know why
you got so upset?
And then he'll tell me why and he's like,
"I miss my friends and
I wanna go to school."
- That's what my kids say.
- Yeah, it's the same so
they're trying to figure out
what's going on with them
too is just, oh, you have
to have some patience with these babies.
- I 100% agree but let's talk about one of
your other passions and congrats
on your new single "Coffee"
and then you actually have
an Instagram Live Show,
called Coffee with Kelly?
- Yes, yes I do.
- I love it!
I wanna talk about Coffee with Kelly
- We're so naughty on
the show in a good way
because like you just said
like prior of course to
like stick shifting
gears, we're all bombarded
with so much Coronavirus
statistics and facts
and new information everyday
to where it kind of soaks up
everything that we are and consumes us
and brings forth anxiety and
that's what it was doing to me.
And I was like I have to break this up
so I came up with Coffee with
Kelly and it's just literally
us having like talking sex and
kinky stuff and just have--
- I love it, I'm in!
- Exactly, its fun!
So, it definitely brings
a light and we have
a really good time.
Yesterday we were talking
about relationships
and quarantine and you know,
some people came on like hard.
- It is, I keep saying this, I
keep going man, there's a lot
of babies are gonna come out
of this and a lot of divorces.
(chuckles)
- It's true.
- It's so hard because we're
always around each other
all the time.
I love that though.
And I don't know if it's a
Kelly thing but I love the fact
that you are very open or a Texas thing
but, you're very open and
Rowland, really, I mean
you know, you're like, oh,
we get nasty and I'm like
Sex ain't nasty, everybody
has sex, everybody does--
- Yeah, everybody does have sex.
- It's like you notice
the way you, approach
all those subjects and
I think it's awesome.
And I think it's really important to have
not just stiff content and
I think it's, you know,
to have real raw content,
just real conversations.
I think it's cool, so congratulations
on that, it's awesome.
- Thank you so much.
- I've always been a fan,
I'm such a big fan of you
but I just want to say thank
you and I want everybody
to check out Kelly's new
show, Coffee with Kelly
on Instagram, as well as
her new single, "Coffee".
Y'all better get that.